si je parle du projet troisième lien à
Québec vous me dites quoi ben moi
pourquoi parce que Québec c'est pas une
région c'est une métropole c'est une
capitale
nationale avec un envergure
international pour le premier
comme ça avec ça dans le milieu
vous n'êtes pas très favorable
c'est économiquement rentable ça va
peut-être faire plus de monde de
touristes qui vont aller là-bas puis
moins de trafic qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez du projet 3e lien un gros
pourquoi pas c'est les gens de Québec
[Musique]
à Québec je dirais plutôt pour le
tramway ça va aider les gens à arriver
plus tôt à leur travail la planète va
faire une crise cardiaque puis nous on
est là là troisième lien je comprends
que les gens ont besoin d'un troisième
lien mais je suis certaine de façon que
ça se passe en ce moment moi je me
tresse côté je réfléchirai
et moi pour être honnête je pense ça va
juste créer du trafic mais plus loin
moi je pense que l'argent qu'on va
investir pour le troisième million
devrait l'investir plus pour l'urgence
climatique
besoin je dis pas non je trouve qu'on
aurait avoir plus de ponts à Montréal
Québec devrait en avoir moins juste là
Monsieur Lego dit que les gens de
Montréal qui s'opposent au 3e lien
regarde les gens de Québec et de les
vidéos
vous en pensez quoi non non c'est pas
une question de regarder oh moi j'aime
pas la distension que le goût créé je
regarde surtout pas les gens de Lévis et
de Québec oh ma belle famille habite à
Québec
on peut survivre ensemble vous avez pas
l'impression de regarder les gens de
Québec de haut au contraire on les adore
un message de paix